>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY THAT MEANS
IT'S TIME FOR OUR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
UNSEEN CLASSICS BERNIE SANDERS
VIDEO AND A FASHION CONSCIOUS
PRINCIPAL.
BIDEN'S LATEST.
>> WHEN YOU ARE RUNNING IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF THE TODAY
YOU HAVE TO CONNECT WITH THE
AVANATI COMMUNITY.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MUSTN'T.
-- COMMUNITY.
BUT ARE THERE BETTER WAYS TO DID
IT.
>> I PUT TOGETHER A BOTTOM TO
TEACH PEOPLE HOW TO CODE.
THEY WENT INTO THE HOOD.
THE MAJORITY WERE WOMEN OF
COLOR.
ONLY A 3rd ABOUT A GED.
>> IN THE HOOK.
HE SAID WE WENT LITERALLY IN THE
HOOD.
GIVING HIS TRACK RECORD WITH THE
STUFF ABOUT OBAMA BEING
ARTICULATE, CLEAN AND BRIGHT.
HE HAS TO WATCH HIMSELF.
THIS IS WHEN YOU NEED JOE BIDEN,
PEOPLE SAYING DON'T SAY HOOD.
>> Laura: OTHER PEOPLE CAN SAY
HOOD?
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE INNER
CITY, IF THEY WANT TO SAY HOOD.
ARE YOU WILL LANGUAGE POLICE
NOW?
I AM STANDING UP FOR JOE BIDEN.
>> I AM REACTING TO WHAT OTHERS
ARE REACTING.
>> Laura: THEY DICTATE WHAT YOU
SAY?
>> YOU CAN'T SAY WE WILL PUT YOU
IN CHAINS AND SAY THINGS ABOUT
DUNCAN DOUGHNUTS.
>> Laura: IF WE SAID THAT WE
WOULD BE CRUCIFIED.
>> A NEW BERNIE SANDERS VIDEO
SURFACED SHOT IN THE 1980s.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE 1880s.
IT WAS CALLED BERNIE SPEAKS WITH
THE COMMUNITY.
HERE HE IS.
>> OKAY.
>> HOLD IT.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
ONE SECOND.
ONE SECOND!
HOLD IT.
WHO KNOWS ABOUT COCAINE?
ANYONE EVER SEEN COCAINE?
ONE AT A TIME.
WHAT ABOUT IT?
>> IF YOU LOOK LIKE SOMEBODY ON
BACK TO THE FUTURE.
>> MICHAEL J FOX OR THE OTHER
GUY.
>> YOU KNOW THE OTHER GUY HE
LOOKS LIKE.
THAT GUY.
>> Laura: [LAUGHING].
>> LIKE DOC BROWN.
THIS IS LIKE A MEAN SPIRITED ART
LINKLETTER.
HE WOULD SIT WITH CHILDREN.
THIS SHOULD BE CALLED SOCIALISTS
SAY THE DARNEDEST THINGS.
BERNIE SANDERS WOULD YOU LIKE A
ROVING REPORTER LIKE JOAN RIVERS
ON THE RED CARPET.
>> THAT'S AN INTERESTING
HAIR-DO.
WHAT DOES YOUR DRESS MEAN?
>> IT'S JUST SAYING TO HECK WITH
SOCIETY.
TO HECK WITH --
>> THE HECK WITH LAW AND ORDER?
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> Laura: SHE IS NOW AN ACCOUNT
MANAGER.
>> IT'S INTERESTING LISTENING TO
THIS.
BERNARD MADE FILM STRIPS FOR
CHILDREN.
>> Laura: I KIND OF LIKE HIM.
HE IS A LIBERAL, ROVING TRIUMPH
INSULT DOG.
>> MICHAEL MOORE BEFORE MICHAEL
MOORE.
>> Laura: LOOKS LIKE BACK TO THE
FUTURE.
>> FINALLY THE PRINCIPAL OF
JAMES MADISON HIGH SCHOOL IN
HOUSTON SPARKED CHARGES OF
RACISM WHEN SHE SENT A LETTER
HOME SAYING THE SCHOOL WILL BE
ENFORCING A NEW DRESS CODE FOR
PARENTS.
>> Laura: A WHITE PRIVILEGED
WOMAN.
>> SHE OUTLAWED PAJAMAS AND
DAISY DUKE SHORTS AND HAIR
ROLLERS.
>> Laura: [APPLAUDING].
>> WHEN ANYONE WALKS IN, WE HAVE
TO MODEL WHAT WE WANT THE
CHILDREN TO KNOW AND SHOW THEM
WHAT IS RIGHT AND CORRECT.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU WON'T WEAR A
SWIMSUIT TO SCHOOL.
YOU WEAR IT TO THE BEACH.
IT'S ABOUT ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE.
>> SHE SAID YOU ARE YOUR CHILD'S
FIRST TEACHER.
I LIKE HOW SHE IS ENFORCING.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE BEEN ON A
PLANE WHEN HERE COMES A GUY WITH
T-SHIRT AND PAJAMAS ON THE
PLANE.
I AM GLAD SHE DID THIS.
>> Laura: I LOVE THE FACT THAT
WOMEN ARE SAYINGUL ARE BETTER
THAN THAT.
THEY WILL SAY YOU ARE JUDGING
ME.
HOW DARE YOU JUDGE ME?
THIS IS MY FASHION TRUTH.
>> SOME FASHION TRUTHS SHOULD BE
KEPT TO THEMSELVES.
THINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE WEARING
TO SCHOOL THAT IRRITATED THE
PRINCIPAL.
THE TIGHT LEGINGS.
OR WHEN MEN SHOW UP LOOKING LIKE
THIS.G
[LAUGHING].GINS.
OR WHEN MEN SHOW UP LOOKING LIKE
THIS.
[LAUGHING].